uh today the government has published
this document
uh the uk's approach to the northern
ireland protocol
now you may remember the back end of
last year when the pm did the deal
for exiting the european union he
insisted there'd be no checks
on the border between uh the republic of
ireland and northern ireland
well it's not quite like that in this
document because
as the document says in one paragraph
some checks will be needed supported by
relevant electronic processes
that's in a section on agri-food uh
there's also another bit also on
agri-food uh it says uh there will be
some limited additional process on goods
arriving in northern ireland
it does say though there will be no new
physical customs infrastructure
we see no need to build any uh we will
however expand some existing entry
points
for agri-food goods to provide for
proportionate
additional controls so checks controls
process now that's in the document um
remember that boris johnson has always
insisted there would be no checks
in an interview with sophie ridge on sky
news and memorably
in when he was talking to business
leaders in northern ireland
in november during the election campaign
there will not be checks on goods going
from northern ireland to great britain
if somebody asked you
to do that tell them to ring up the
prime minister
and i will direct them to throw that
form in the bin look at what we say in
our manifesto look what we're going to
deliver the deal that we've done so will
there be checks
no absolutely not
throw them in the bin said the prime
minister well uh
more exchanges between the governments
and brussels
here we have the reply from michelle
barnier
to the uh letter sent by david frost
yesterday which we reported on
do you remember that uh david frost was
complaining
that the british government was
perplexed about some of the things
that brussels was demanding negotiations
on the things like tariffs and so on as
michael gove put it yesterday
the eu's insisting that we want with the
uk has to uh
play by the rules of a club that it no
longer belongs to well today
mr barnier is hit back saying i would
not like the tone that you've taken to
impact the mutual trust
and constructive attitudes essential
between us he says the place to have
these discussions is in the
formal negotiations and uh he says at
one point um
regardless of what your letter suggests
there's no automatic entitlement to any
benefits that the eu may have offered
or granted in other contexts and
circumstances to other
very different partners now that was in
response to uh mr frost saying look
you're offering this to other countries
why can't we
have that deal anyway the last paragraph
says uh
uh i remain uh convinced that with uh
mutual respect and constructive
engagement we can move forward
in the limited available time he does
talk about the need for a new
dynamism though in order to avoid a
stalemate
and stalemate is where they are at the
moment